[Music]
the funeral this week of vetoed ashurek
a belarussian political prisoner
sentenced just last month to five years
in jail
[Music]
his wish to be buried beneath the red
and white flag of a free belarus
honoured by those who mourned him
this video released by the belarussian
authorities of ashurik's final hours
just before he staggers and falls head
first
a terrible warning his best friend says
of how far the authorities are prepared
to go
in the russian resort of sochi the
belarusian leader alexander lukashenko
met with the one world leader
on whom his regime now depends
i'll show you some documents you will
see what's going on and what happened
there
it's an attempt to destabilize the
situation like in august last year
it is not only journalist roman protest
whose fate hangs in the balance after he
was detained off ryanair flight 4978
but his girlfriend too a 23 year old
russian citizen
about whom russia seems remarkably
unfast
told sky news she does not expect his
release anytime soon
belarus's nominal opposition leader in
exile svetlana tikanovskaya
called for a new national strike and for
stronger action from the eu
i insist that we can't look at this
issue with flight
separately from the situation itself
that
this issued flight is the result of
the impunity of luka central
but nationwide strikes and domestic
protests since rigged elections last
august have faltered
in the face of soviet-style repressions
and so far the backlash to this act of
state piracy
has only pushed the perpetrator closer
into the kremlin's hands
diana magney sky news moscow